Wrong.
In this multicultural, intersectional society,
where more of us are gathered and raised
by people and with etiquette unlike our own,
where we don't share the etiquette,
unspoken norms are trouble,
whereas pop-up rules allow us to connect meaningfully.
They're one-time-only constitutions for a specific purpose.
So a team dinner,
where different generations are gathering
and don't share the same assumptions of phone etiquette:
whoever looks at their phone first
foots the bill.
(Laughter)
Try it.
(Applause)
For an entrepreneurial advice circle of just strangers,
where the hosts don't want everybody to just listen
to the one venture capitalist in the room --
(Laughter)
knowing laugh --
you can't reveal what you do for a living.
For a mom's dinner,
where you want to upend the norms
of what women who also happen to be mothers talk about when they gather,
if you talk about your kids, you have to take a shot.
(Laughter)
That's a real dinner.
Rules are powerful,
because they allow us to temporarily change and harmonize our behavior.
And in diverse societies,
pop-up rules carry special force.
They allow us to gather across difference,
to connect,
to make meaning together
without having to be the same.
When I was a child,
I navigated my two worlds by becoming a chameleon.
If somebody sneezed in my mother's home,
I would say, "Bless you,"
in my father's, "God bless you."
To protect myself, I hid,
as so many of us do.
And it wasn't until I grew up and through conflict work
that I began to stop hiding.
And I realized that gatherings for me,
at their best,
allow us to be among others,
to be seen for who we are,
and to see.
The way we gather matters
because how we gather
is how we live.
Thank you.
(Applause)